[Music]
striking shapes unusual materials and
new production methods these glasses are
certainly eye-catching and they have
something else in common they were all
designed in Berlin the German capital
has become the place to find the latest
in fashionable eyewear the designers at
loonette's produce glasses in limited
editions of no more than 1,000 pairs
their latest design our cooperation with
Belgian fashion label Caparo features
lenses fastin with rubber bands
what's special about them is that
they're made from one piece of material
using a 3d printer and what's nice is
you can use different colors of rubber
bands initially loonette's sold vintage
frames but increasingly the firm is
focusing on its own designs which
Claudia Drexel and her colleagues sell
to customers worldwide many fashionistas
come to Berlin especially to buy glasses
there are many labels such as the big
brands which have established themselves
globally but new additions - and Berlin
boasts many really different styles one
of the pioneers of the scene was Ralph
and Elle he founded the icy Berlin brand
back in 1996 it produced lightweight
stainless steel frames with a
revolutionary screwless hinge system yes
and wolff are added from the initial
design was based on simplicity and the
question of which hinge suits the
material you brush this deal with your
fingertips and you try to listen to what
it's telling you Faysal also - fast
agree flustered good today I see Berlin
is one of Berlin's major eyewear
manufacturers the firm produces its own
frames entirely in the German capital
how undle believes it's no coincidence
that many independent labels have set up
shop here the city does still have a lot
of innovative spirit and it's relatively
affordable you can develop things in a
pretty relaxed manner you don't have to
keep your eye on the money straight away
like you do in other cities where you
have to be highly efficient here you can
play around a bit and just sort of ease
into this serious business life he 9
Haiti's international stars have become
fans of German made glasses i see
Berlin's customers include Brad Pitt
Madonna and Alicia Keys British singers
skin and American talk show host Oprah
Winfrey swear by glasses from Kubo home
the brand was founded by two Italians
living in Berlin their heavy
acetate frames are their trademark and
their slogan is dreamed in Berlin
it's a city which gives the possibility
to see the world from another point of
view
so actually since we started we put
another point of view in in the world of
eyewear whether they are well
established or new in the business
Berlin designers create glasses for the
fashion conscious avant-garde not the
masses because we don't produce on such
a large scale we're flexible when it
comes to sizes and colors and through
our direct contact with our customers we
also hear what needs to be done what's
not available most of us need
[Music]
spectacles that are made in Berlin do
more than help people see better they're
an eye-catching design accessory
[Music]